perhaps no major metropolitan area on
Florida's west coast is more vulnerable
to catastrophic flooding then the Tampa
Bay area since the 1920s the Tampa st.
Petersburg area has managed to dodge a
number of hurricanes but it appears that
Armour will end that lucky streak
tonight winds are expected to top out at
nearly 130 miles an hour and the storm
surge could reach eight feet David beg
no is in Tampa right now with why the
threat there is so great David good
morning Gail good morning knowing what's
coming
it is spooky how quiet it is right now
Tampa hasn't been hit by a major
hurricane in nearly 100 years and a lot
has changed since then
including the sea level when we talk
about the Tampa Bay area we're talking
about nearly 700 miles of coastline that
is vulnerable to flooding and as sea
levels have risen this area has become
one of the most endangered coastal
communities in the world with Irma
threatening to turn sun-drenched Tampa
into a waterlogged nightmare ken Ward
was scrambling to save his business on
Saturday if the surge comes in we our
bottom floor is going to be toasted it's
going to be gone Tim Connor knows all
too well what heavy rain means for his
st. Petersburg home in 1985 hurricane
Elena cracked the foundation of his
house forcing him to rebuild his home
now stands 12 feet above sea level
but his evacuation route is prone to
flooding I actually tell people we're
four blocks from the bay or we're in the
bay there's not an in-between because
we're so low that like I said when a
good rain comes through high tide
we're in the bay the city of Tampa has
been working to upgrade the area's aging
infrastructure spending 251 million
dollars to address chronic flooding
scuba divers have even dredged debris
out of pipes to ensure better water flow
we are challenged here in Tampa with our
older system and the topography that we
have is very makes it very challenging
for us to develop projects that are
really impactful because of the low
elevations we have and lots of rain that
we have - another challenge is
population growth the number of people
living in the Tampa Bay area has
increased by more than 85,000 since 2000
many people living along the coast at
the same time Tampa Bay's sea levels
have recently accelerated projections
now show water rising up to two and a
half feet by 2050 the area is especially
vulnerable to the kind of storm surge
that permit could bring when I was
growing up I used to love the rain don't
love it so much anymore st. Petersburg
mayor Rick Christman says the extra
rainfall lately is straining out-of-date
systems but in st. Pete we're living
with an infrastructure that you know
quite frankly wasn't maintained to the
level it should have been and our
federal government certainly doesn't
provide us with resources to invest in
our infrastructure in the way we need to
if ARMA slams into Tampa with the kind
of force that some forecasters expect it
may create devastating damage unleashing
powerful winds and a storm surge that
would be several feet think about that
the typical the typical first story is
seven to ten feet five to eight feet
this is a life-threatening situation the
mayor of st. Petersburg says previous
administrations didn't take the threat
of climate change seriously kick the can
down the road and now he says
implementing the kind of changes they
want to make will take years
we're along side the Hillsborough River
here is the grave concern as air moves
in the storm surge that's going to come
in through Tampa Bay is gonna hit this
choke point it's got nowhere to go
Charlie so as the water starts to spread
I'm standing on what is essentially the
road level we could be swimming where
I'm standing within the next 18 hours
and everything around here could be
under water that's the expectation David
thanks